new questions are emerging over the so
called transcript of president Trump's
phone call to Ukraine's president that
led to this impeachment inquiry a
National Security Council official
that's Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Ben
Minh told investigators yesterday that
the official summary of the call is
missing some information Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill with more on that story
his testimony yesterday Nancy was very
revealing what else did he say in this
very heated hearing well Gail he said
that he tried unsuccessfully to correct
the summary of that presidential phone
call remember that this call was
considered so problematic that the
records ended up getting stored on a
highly classified server he is the first
person to testify about actually
listening in on the call itself in real
time as the White House point person on
Ukraine policy Colonel Vint Minh made a
very strong case that what the President
did happened and was very very wrong
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander vind Minh
told house investigators he did not
think it was proper for President Trump
to urge the Ukrainian president to
investigate Joe Biden he was bothered by
what he heard and felt duty-bound to
express his concern to a superior a
source in the deposition told CBS News
VIN Minh had also warned that the
summary of the president's July 25th
phone call was missing certain words one
was a reference to BER yzma the energy
company that hired hunter Biden to serve
on its board the White House summary is
less specific
it has zalenski referencing quote the
company according to the New York Times
VIN Minh said the summary also omitted
president Trump's reference to
recordings of Joe Biden talking about
Ukrainian corruption bin Minh said he
tried to get those omissions included
but was rebuffed another source said VIN
Minh testified he didn't believe the
words were left out for nefarious
reasons and while one Democrat called
ven-ven's testimony the nail in the
coffin Republicans called it his opinion
I thanked him for his service I think
his commitment to
country but he is wrong in this the
house will vote on a resolution tomorrow
that creates a new roadmap for the
impeachment inquiry Democrats say it
opens up the process but it's not what
Republicans had in mind we can't stand
for this the American people are being
denied equal justice the resolution
gives Republicans the right to submit to
the chair in writing requests for
witness testimony but those requests can
still be denied by Democrats in a
statement the White House said the
president's rights remain undefined
unclear and dismissed the inquiry as an
illegitimate sham this process has been
illegitimate the Senate's Republican
leader disagreed do you view the house
impeachment inquiry as illegitimate
impeachment there's a practical matter
is whatever a majority of the house
decides it is at any given moment during
ven mins deposition yesterday a shouting
match reportedly broke out between
Democrats and Republicans as Democrats
accused their GOP counterparts of trying
to unearth the identity of a White House
whistleblower afterwards House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi warned against that calling
of the outing of the whistleblower an
unpatriotic at action that no one should
try to attempt Tony all right Nancy
Cordes for us on Capitol Hill Nancy
thank you very much